ولكن الان كما نتابع الجيش اللبناني اكدا
والمخابرات اللبنانيه ايضا الافراج عن هذا
المختطف في عمليه نوعيه نتابع مره اخرى
التقاليد تتحدث عن ان الجيش قد تعرف على
هويه اربعه من خاطفي المواطن السعودي
وداهم منزلهم وهو يقول ايضا ان تحرير
المواطن السعودي المختطف جاء بعد عمليه
نوعيه على الحدود مع سوريا وقال ان ثلاثه
من خاطفي المواطن السعودي كانوا يرتدون
زيا عسكريا وهم ليسوا عسكريين نتابع اذا
مشاهدينا معكم هذه الصور لقوات الامن
اللبنانيه في احدى المناطق والتي سيطر
التي
اذا رئيس الوزراء لبناني مشاهدينا يقول
اننا حريصون على منع اي تهديد يطال العرب
في لبنان نذكر المشاهدين ايضا بان مصادر
السلطات اللبنانيه تحدثت عن ان الخاطفين
انتقلوا
بالمختطف الى منطقه
الى منطقه في جنوب العاصمه اللبنانيه وقد
اكد ايضا الان رئيس الوزراء اللبناني او
ان خطف احد المواطنين السعوديين هو فعل
مدان بكل المعايير
لمتابعه المزيد
من الاقمج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات